[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti se esiste una
formula segreta per superare le
difficoltà le difficoltà pratiche
emotive professionali fate un po le
sfide di ogni giorno le sfide di ognuno
di noi
beh io me lo sono chiesta e non avendo
trovato risposta inizialmente ho fatto
la prima cosa che una ragazza della
generazione z potesse fare nucleare
sperando poi appunto qualcun altro
magari qualche altro ted speaker avesse
già risolto questo dilemma
ebbene sì qualcuno l'ho trovato poco ho
trovato è stato tom wujec che un
grandissimo venere della tecnologia e le
consiglia di disegnare la preparazione
di un toast si propose la preparazione
di un posto sembra assurdo senza senso
ma si tratta di un esempio di
destrutturazione del problema
sminuzzarle fino a renderli invisibili
minuscoli insignificanti e facilmente
risolvibili
poi ho trovato in finance in consulenti
analitico che dà un consiglio molto
genitoriale punto consiglia dice
dobbiamo smetterla a tutti se anche voi
in prima fila di compararci alle altre
persone
siamo un po tutti i contorti non è vero
bene perciò mi sono detta chiederò ai
nemici come tale non è dovete scusarmi
poi tra l'altro se non mi sono ancora
presentata io appunto o vent'anni
compiuti da poco due settimane ci tengo
a sottolinearlo e sono una grande
studentessa è una grande appassionata di
innovazione tecnologica si è un modo
carinissimo per dire che sono una grande
merd però sapete quelli innovazione
utile è che genera impatto sulle persone
e sull'ambiente bene
fatto ciò che bisognava fare altro è
essere educati con chi non si conosce
ancora vi dico cosa hanno risposto il
mio amici alla domanda sempre quella
iniziale esiste una formula vincente per
superare le difficoltà dunque rijkaard
un mio amico dice che la sua ricetta
segreta è raccontare alle persone di cui
si fida data alta voce il suo dilemma
mentre parla gli si schiariscono le idee
come se come si soffiassero via i
problemi
non so se li raccolgono gli altri però
sicuramente danno una mano a capire
meglio
poi c'è maria maria dice spesso che per
lavoro si trova di fronte a situazioni
emotivamente stressanti o indiziata in
difficoltà di relazione davanti allo
stress emotivo cerca modi per alleviare
la sofferenza propria ed altrui per
esempio lei mi hanno raccontato che usa
passare lo smalto sulle unghie alle sue
piccole pazienti oppure cerca di
strappare qualche sorriso qualche
battuta dunque il suo un caso
particolare perché le sue difficoltà
sono strettamente intrecciate a quelle
dei suoi pazienti
ecco io vi ho detto finora degli altri
però se sono più a parlare adesso è il
momento anche di i racconti io vi
racconti di come io come sempre io
faccio quindi come stanno le cose per me
ecco io da sempre da piccola ho sempre
versato moltissime lacrime e così quella
sono io
certo è piangevo spesso che andiamo
spesso niente di patetico è soltanto per
un unico motivo di scelte da prendere
ogni volta che si riproponevano scelte
scambi di programmi e virate improvvise
destra a sinistra pizza o film dolce o
salato era un macello
non so per voi pensate beh è più micro
chavo di non voler scegliere più le
scelte si facevano fastidiose sembrava
quasi che si accumulassero o che
crescessero aumentando esponenzialmente
fino a diventare problemi o rebus
ecco non so se voi riuscite a risolvere
i rebus
non so se voi avete mai provato a
risolvere la settimana enigmistica
quanti di voi facciamo piccolo sondaggio
come hanno fatto gli altri spingere ok
io nutro veramente tanta stima per voi
perché io non ci sono mai riuscita
però adesso quindi vi dicevo cercavo di
certo non potevo continuare a piangere
perché altrimenti mi si sarebbero
seccati dotti lacrimali e allora mi
serviva un metodo una formula ho
cominciato a fare piccoli esperimenti
per esempio ho iniziato a giocare a
scacchi
non so se voi sapete giocare a scacchi
però sapete che quando il giocatore fa
una mossa poi non può mai più ritornare
indietro e quindi mi teneva lì è nata ma
era ancora una bambina cioè cercavo
appunto di far quello che potevo
e alla fine ce l'ho fatta ho trovato un
format unico molto personale che mi
aiutasse a risolvere il mio problema di
pianto davanti alle scelte
aspettate questo però importante non
voglio avvisarvi tutti che non so dirvi
se questo sia vincente sono ancora in
fase sperimentale
vi racconto però adesso di tre momenti
della mia vita in cui il mio format è
stato indispensabile per superare quelle
difficoltà da piccolino appunto c'era
sempre qualcosa che non mi piaceva
dell'ambiente in cui vivevo sentivo una
specie di mancanza oppure devo dire che
sono stata molto molto fortunata la mia
una bella famiglia
se gli avessi chiesto di andare sulla
luna probabilmente mi ci avrebbero
portato quindi mi hanno sempre lasciato
molta libertà di scelta probabilmente
forse perché avevano notato che c'era
qualche leggera difficoltà nel prenderne
proprio per questo sin dalle elementari
e la ricerca di quel qualcosa quel
qualcuno che colmasse la mia mancanza
cercavo di convincere adulti a seguire i
miei progetti imprenditoriali
praticamente nemmeno dieci anni già mi
sentivo un'imprenditrice di successo
manager ho scoperto poi che quel
qualcosa erano le opportunità un posto o
delle persone con cui mettere a terra
tutti i miei progetti
durante l'estate dei miei 18 anni mi
trovavo in california come premio per
aver vinto un contest nazionale e lì ho
incontrato alcune delle persone più
straordinari che io abbia mai conosciuto
e confrontandomi con loro notiziona ho
scoperto che mi
rimane condiviso per noi studenti
italiani era ed è difficile riconoscere
le opportunità e allo stesso tempo
ricevere attenzioni riguarda i nostri
progetti
eravamo venti ragazze sotto i 18 anni e
tutti accomunati da situazioni molto
simili
da allora in poi ho conosciuto sempre
più giovani italiani intraprendenti
desiderosi di fare e pieni di sogni se
tutti in giro per il cyberspazio
voglio citarne alcuni perché ricordo per
esempio sarà valeria matteo andreo
andrea che dopo un progetto in svezia
poi si sono uniti a noi diciottenni
della california per risolvere il nostro
cubo di rubik generazionale eravamo
tutti erano tutte eccellenze tutti
diversi provenienti sia da grande città
che da posti sperduti soprattutto da
posto in post perduti e grazie all'aiuto
dei miei amici lasci contact of contact
contatto nonché la risposta al mio rebus
un progetto per ragazzi dai 14 e 18 anni
per quei ragazzini che come me si
agitavano alla ricerca di quel calcolo
di quel qualcosa
un progetto che ti fa rendere conto di
poter cambiare il mondo e con chi farlo
si sembra un ambizioso in realtà lo è ma
andiamo al secondo momento
e questa la cape wrath è certamente ne
sono sicura se vi dico marzo 2020
intorno al giorno 9 quando l'ex
presidente del consiglio giuseppe conte
dichiarò lock down generale come vi
siete sentiti in quel momento io
impotente poi dopo il primo smarrimento
pensato che avrei voluto fare qualcosa
per aiutare il mio piccolo ovviamente e
tutte le persone che sarei riuscito ad
aiutare follia
ho fatto la cosa che più mi viene meglio
ovvero conoscere persone in giro per il
cyberspazio e generare idee per qualche
assurdo motivo sapevo avevo la sicurezza
che qualcuno mi avrebbe ascoltata
difatti ho conosciuto roman un signore
su una quarantina d'anni lituano
giovanile nel modo di fare e poi con uno
sfondo su john stellato fighissimo
abbiamo chiacchierato a lungo online e
ne ha raccontato di un alti di un'idea
folle che era bastata per la testa
pregando sti car e il copy 19 attraverso
i flussi della voce in quei giorni
riflettevo tanto sulla voce perché
comunque era stata molto meno perché non
c'era scuola
ripensavo ai miei allenamenti di te
quando dove il fiato veniva parecchio
messo veniva messo parecchio alla prova
precedentemente e soprattutto lo stesso
fiato che mancava ai malati di covi 19
quindi non me lo fece dire due volte
volevo essere parte di quel progetto ma
soprattutto forse avevo trovato una
chiave per risolvere il mio rebus quindi
per 4 e spunk abili mesi abbiamo
lavorato ad un progetto giorno e notte
brees per rispettare fusi orari di tutti
i partecipanti perché arteam si
aggiungevano sempre più persone
desiderose di aiutare ricordo lisa un
assistente sanitario dal brasile ricordo
ai gb e un medico e chirurgo dall'india
e tantissimi altri provenienti da tutto
il mondo e soprattutto con con
competenze diverse e poi c'ero io chiara
la prima italiana ma soprattutto la più
giovane ma soprattutto ancora la
mascotte ero di nuovo insieme a
tantissime altre meravigliose persone
tutte diverse e stavolta anche
culturalmente per risolvere un problema
condiviso per realizzare un algoritmo in
grado di predire istigare il comite
attraverso i flussi della voce
poi però
dopo quattro mesi di incessante lavoro
lo stop brusco improvviso ho dovuto
lasciare tutto in maniera repentina
tutte le mie responsabilità tutti i
compiti presi ed è così che arriviamo
all'ultimo momento
adesso vi faccio un ultima domanda e
giuro che è l'ultima
vi chiedo di chiudere gli occhi tutti
per 10 secondi
qual è l'ultima cosa che fareste se mai
venisse a sapere di avere giorni contati
la visualizzate riuscite ad immaginarla
sentendola profondamente
ecco ora aggiungeteci un paio di
variabili avere 18 anni ed essere nel
pieno di una pandemia ecco la difficoltà
improvvisa la terza di cui appunto vi
parlerò adesso mi ha fatto rispondere
con una domanda curarmi io ecco come
potete capire da questa domanda che vi
ho fatto aveva un problemino da
risolvere assolutamente senza sapere
come sapendo che allo stesso tempo di
dovermi affidare completamente medici
avete presente la mosca cieca o il gioco
della pignatta
bene ecco io brancolava tra mille paure
e la mia pignatta era un linfoma
ma non sono qui per deprimermi
assolutamente né per fare la patetica
anzi sono qui per raccontarvi come ho
superato un momento correndo trovando
forza e risorse in primis
dopo tutto l'allenamento fatto di cui vi
parlavo prima un po mi sentivo corazzata
mi sentivo pronta a testare nuovamente
il mio format vincente tipo un format
4.46 punto 69.9 ho iniziato ad hackerare
la mia difficoltà tra questo
c'era davanti a mille esami di maturità
orazio leopardi schopenhauer consulenti
d'eccezione per un finale scolastico col
botto
nei mesi successivi ho conosciuto più di
duemila persone tra quelli tutte o a
nord poco vip che ovviamente li ho
conosciuti dal cyberspazio dal mio letto
ma spesso anche quello a quello
dell'ospedale o finalmente preso scelte
o generato opportunità per gli altri e
di conseguenza per me ma soprattutto
insieme alle altre persone con la mia
famiglia la mia mamma mio papà che vedo
in platea i miei amici quelli del
cyberspazio e non ho ragionato su come
restituire piano piano tutto ciò quello
tutto ciò che mi sta che stavo imparando
e che le persone mi stavano dando ormai
è ormai passato un anno e un mese da
quel primo giorno in cui mi feci quelle
domande e inizia ad analizzare il mio
problema ed è passato più di un decennio
dal mio primo pianto
però posso alla fine rispondere alla
domanda possa inizialmente esiste una
formula segreta per superare le
difficoltà
bene io il mio form vincente l'ho
trovato e spero che a questo punto possa
aiutare tutti voi solare tutti voi
servono uno sguardo panoramico prima e
poi su ogni dettaglio del problema
un pizzico di rischio un tuffo nel
coraggio un respiro profondo di pazienza
anche due facciamo tre e la voglia di
ascoltare gli altri cantare con loro a
tutti a voce anche a costo di suonare
grazie
[Applauso]